one thing we do know China is battling a
covert Outbreak on precisely what scale
is much less clear pictures from State
tv give an impression of an orderly
response officially just 13 people have
died of the virus in December today
president Xi Jinping insisted China was
following the science
since covid-19 struck all along we have
put the people first and put life first
following a science-based and targeted
approach but unofficially the picture is
much Bleaker these images show cues
outside funeral homes in cities across
China One UK data firm estimates there
are nine thousand deaths occurring every
day the lack of clarity from China poses
problems for the rest of the world
several countries including the UK have
now imposed testing requirements on
arrivals from China so those arriving at
airports like here at Heathrow will have
to show proof of a negative test but
there's considerable debate as to
whether such policies have any
scientific Merit or whether they're more
political responses to the need to be
seen to act for example 24 direct
flights are scheduled to arrive in the
UK from China in the next week that's an
average of just over a thousand
passengers a day even if we assume that
every single person on board the those
flights is infected it would still add
just 0.4 percent to the Daily covert
caseload which currently stands at over
230 000 new infections every day
certainly it's not going to do anything
to reduce the amount of covid that's in
the UK particularly if you think of all
the other people coming in from other
countries potentially with covid but
sequencing does make sense a sequence a
random subsample of passengers coming in
um from China yes uh simply because
they're not showing their sequencing
data just because there's no evidence at
the moment are there any dangerous
variants from China but it also makes
sense to do it for many other
destinations but it seems that the UK
has decided to ER on the side of caution
here in Bournemouth we have critical
incident status because of the number of
Covenant flu cases for example do we
want to really add to that can we be a
hundred percent sure that Britain would
be safe if we don't take these measures
if there's a doubt there then it's
absolutely right that we act as the
government has really done and that's a
dangerous new variant does emerge it
seems unlikely these scenes from China
will be repeated here in the UK and if
it does travel restrictions will only
delay its arrival here vigilance though
will help us catch it early and help
prepare the world Matthew Thompson Sky
News